father passed away. I'm so sorry to hear
that, man.
To either reward you and our deepest of
condolences. He was in America or
overseas.
Overseas.
Our brother was here, his
father just passed away.
Make a brief dua for him. Inshallah.
[Silence]
for
Allah.
Allah
Fore!
[Silence]
Foreign! Foreign!
Jenn
[Silence]
saychech.
Allham,
our deepest condolences. May Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala forgive his sins and
raise his levels.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
So in the previous
chapter here in the book of purification
regarding aum we just discussed a few
narrations that the author narrates to
us here regarding the instances and
excuses that would
allow or give way to an allowance of
making in place of using water to make
or
he mentions to us an irration
about a person who doesn't have enough
water. He mentions to us an irration
about someone who is mortally ill and
was affected adversely by this water
which actually killed him. And he
mentions to us an irration of bitter
cold. So let's look at these three
instances. We have a person who doesn't
have water.
Number two, we have a person who is
unable to use the water because of a
problem in himself in his body. And then
we have a person who's unable to use the
water because a problem in the in the
environment. Right? All of these warrant
usage of aum in place of water. Right?
You would be surprised or maybe you
wouldn't how many urgent urban legends
and myths are found amongst people
with respect to.
You have some people that never used and
never will because they find it to be
you know too easy. And then you have
the other extreme of people who use
if they have to walk to their car for
five minutes, right? There is a middle
ground to be had. You'd be amazed how
many people have asked me or confirmed
to me that they're here and maybe like
for instance they go on a hike or they
go to Mount Lemon or something that
and then they make it to Yum. Why?
because there's no water in the car and
you know you have to prioritize your
salah. If there's no water in the car,
you get in your car and you drive down
the road to get the water, right? The
instance in which you would not have
access to water is there's no way
to get where I'm going and make and
catch the salah in time. In that
situation, you make a however if you're
able to go somewhere to get water and
you will catch the salah in its rightful
time, that is what is obligatory upon
you.
he says here to us
next chapter is what is
because Allah tells us that
He says you do not have water
then
use
because
in the Arabic language is to take
something and use it something that
sticks to something else that's why it's
called
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions it in
its linguistic sense
This is in a linguistic sense and it's
referred to as aum because a person is
utilizing whatever of the dirt or
dust or what have you sticks to their
hands that which is left over. This is
why it's called
but Allah tells us to use a he gives us
two parameters for what is used for a
number one that it has to be
number two it has to be
it has to be
and it has to be which means pure
So the two descriptions are and pure.
What is
comes from the root word which means to
climb or to ra rise above something. You
say
meaning rose and climbed upon the member
until he settled on top of the member.
So
as a verb means that something rises
over something else and and settles
there. So what is a in the Arabic
language? It is anything that naturally
settles on top of the surface of the
earth.
What what is that? Dirt. Does it fit
that description? Dirt. Dust. Does it
fit that description? Sand. Does it fit
that description? Yes. All of these
things you can make
with because the point is that it is
settles on top of surfaces of the earth.
You know the this podium right here.
Does it have dust on it right now? Yes.
Could you make the yum from this podium?
Yes. The wall, especially in Arizona
with all this sand and dirt flying
around in the air, could you make demum
from it? Yes.
the dashboard in your car if you're
not, you know, obsessively cleaning your
car every every couple days. That layer
of dust that settles, can you make with
that? Is it pure? Yes. Did it settle
naturally on top of on top of the
surface? Yes. Therefore, you can make a
teum with it.
Some say no. It has to be dirt. And we
say there's no evidence for that.
Dirt is part of it, but it's to make it
exclusively have to be dirt. Not
correct. I want you to imagine something
with me. The companions madeum far more
than we do because of the nature of
their travel, because of the nature of
their environment.
They made tyum often
when they would set out to travel often
times when they are between wells
they have to conserve their water and
it's a matter of life and death. So they
would often make
and
in all this desert if any of you have
ever been to the desert right the
desert of the Arab peninsula
it's a different kind of desert than
this desert that we're here in Arizona.
This is a desert that is sand.
It doesn't have dirt. doesn't have
you know places where you can grow
fruits and vegetables. It's extremely
desolate.
So it'd be very hardressed to find dirt
out there in these sands.
If they're constantly making tom, we
should have multiple narrations and
accounts of them carrying dirt with them
on their travels. But they never did.
Never once never once did the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam tell them to
never once was any companion ever
narrated to have carried his own dirt
with him in order to make
right rather aum
is not necessarily dirt it is anything
that settles naturally on top of the
earth or surfaces and is pure
in an airplane it's not possible to make
wudoo. It is possible to make woudoo in
the airplane obviously, but let's say an
instance where it's not. If you reach
over on top of the,
you know, where you put your carry-on
baggage, there's dust up there. Can you
make with that? Yes. The prophet
sallall.aii wasallam was narrated to
have made off of a wall. He was narrated
to have made off of a rock.
from many different places. The
narration of the prophet Sam
that we mention in Bkari Muslim tells us
that the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said
he said I have been given five things
that no other prophet before me has been
given. And one of those five things,
[Silence]
One of those things is that the entire
earth has been made a place for prayer
and a place that you can purify yourself
for salah from meaning.
And in another wording he says any man
amongst my ummah whom the time of salah
enters upon him he has wherever he
stands his purification and his place of
prayer meaning
right. So
the parameters of what you use forum
there are two two descriptions. Number
one
meaning anything that settles naturally
on surfaces. Number two
that it is pure. Right?
Here
he mentions something that Mandur
collected in his book is a major it's a
very big lexicon in Arabic language. He
says
day. He was
for.
[Silence]
So here ib mur tells us that a is
the face of the earth or it is all that
settles upon the face of the earth and
it does not need to be of any particular
thing dirt or sand or dust. He said a
person makes off of the surface of
anything that is present to him. So for
instance, Ibn Mur says hence for
instance if a person happens to be in a
granite place a place where it's all
rock it's all stone and he put his hands
on the face of that stone to make
he has done what Allah has commanded
even if to the naked eye it doesn't
appear that there's anything on his
hands because
is the face of the earth or anything
which resides on the face of the earth
and settles. And so when a person puts
his hands on it this, right?
Tomorrow we'll discuss the description
of how to make
super easy. You can learn it in about 10
seconds.
Is anything on the face of the earth?
Anything. If a person's in a hospital
room, do they need you to go outside and
get a rock for them and not a slippery
rock? It has to be a porous rock. It has
to be a rock that is dusty. It has to be
a rock that is, you know, , rough. And
that's the only way to make the
absolutely not. The wall right next to
him is the ammo. That's the piece of
plastic at the top of the hospital bed
where there's dust. That's anything like
that is
remember this is not a physical
purification.
It's not a physical thing. When I do
this and I wipe my face and my hands
this, what did I just clean? What
did I clean? What is that? It's
figurative. It is ceremonious.
It is it is a routine a you know a
physical act that represents
purification for prayer. It represents
that I'm preparing myself to make salah.
That's it. It's not physically cleaning
anything. Whether it's dirt or not,
whether it's visible to the naked eye or
[Arabic recitation]
work. Hey.
you're there, I want you to remember
that I'm going home to go to sleep right
now. Okay? So, while you're at work,
imagine me sleeping
on. Okay?
And your heart out.